I really really don't like turkey you're
not cooking it properly what do you mean
I'm not cooking I've tried many recipe
I've tried everything put the stcky
bacon on top and put the butter between
B baste baste yeah but it's bland it's
dry it's not and let it rest for as long
as you cook
[Music]
it what about over there come
on say is there a whole saffron
finally
oh goodness me are you you okay yeah I
think so I'm Fred Lind Ducker moved to
Morocco 7 years ago and started her Farm
sahor saffron by hand planting 8 tons of
crocus bulbs she now produces some of
the highest grade saffron in the world
is it one unique flower or can you guess
saffron from different variety of
flowers there's only one crocus flow
that produces saffron that is the most
important the red threads if you get a
flower that has more than three we all
regard it as a lucky break like a four
Le Clover why are they all women in the
field it's considered to be Woman's Work
we made it more delicate I mean look his
sausage finger you could not pick up a
saffron the only thing you can pick up
is a fillet steak trust me I can pick up
saff gin do you want this line this one
here yeah that's it that's it P me down
so beautiful I've never picked saffron
before ever I'm just mad about
saffron saffron's mad about me last year
we had a bump Harvest for kilos so
that's what makes it so expensive yeah a
gram of saffron contains 500 threads
that can sell for up to
£75 making it more expensive than
[Music]
gold Gino what stay in your lane there's
no uh flowers in there stay you're not
looking prop look at the flowers you're
missing you can't just pick different
people's Lanes guys can I can I just let
you know there's some ladies are working
in silence yes they people we we
screaming like this in your kitchen Gord
he's jumping over Lanes you need to
complete the lane you can't just go
where the flowers are look I'm not deaf
you don't have to
shout hello hello can I take
yours
one sec I need another tray guys well
done guys excuse me you you sto from the
ladies you just went to the girl over
there there is no no I have been
breaking my back here and that's all I
got and I haven't been talking oh you're
too slow and you are a
cheater is it true that saffron uh it
makes your wheelie going like Ping like
like I wouldn't say it was that fast but
people with that sort of dysfunction it
has been shown anecdotally of course it
works that's a nice car that's a nice
one these Berber ladies extract a
staggering 2 million red threads every
Harvest worth around
£30,000 hey I feel very relaxed being
here yeah because you can he to bees
it's very quiet and calm they say that
when you're picking saffron it makes you
happy why because over Millennia they've
used saffron to help people who are
depressed now I understand why it's so
expensive because it's so time consuming
and you need to have all these hands
working my God what a labor of love this
is I have a
four
[Music]
strand 1 2 3
4 that means good
luck you just ruined my Christmas I was
all excited and
boom